you know we have we have a video
dispatch from an actual local news
meteorologist to help us explain how
they make their predictions happen let's
check it out
hello dr. Tyson Nick Gregory here at the
Fox 5 Weather Center in New York City
coming up with a weather forecast with
all the raw data we get from NOAA and
other sources really is a science huge
amounts of data that get plugged into
various computer models which then
present a solution we take that solution
apply our own knowledge of past weather
events and predict what we think is
going to happen for example let's see
how we would predict a potential
blizzard so we would start to look for
those weather trends what would they be
let's say high pressure ridging in from
eastern Canada we would then look to the
computer models to see what type of jet
stream pattern would be in play and
would this trough of low pressure be
along the east coast potentially with
this jet stream riding up the eastern
seaboard pockets of energy then start
moving across the country this
upper-level energy that once it reaches
the east coast sets the potential for a
storm to develop right in this location
that storm could then intensify and turn
into a nor'easter and eventually tracked
up along that Jetstream track leaving a
swath of heavy snow alongside so there
you have it perhaps not the most
accurate forecast but we do work with
science and technology so that forecast
will improve over time yeah I know this
guy
I mean he's our local weather guy it's
not you throw him some work so to
improve accuracy it's not just an
academic exercise it matters and what's
the biggest reason why we need accurate
disaster forecast from you well for one
thing it saves lives right I mean if we
can know that a hurricane is gonna
explosively gain and strength in advance
we can get people out of the way in time
for example if we can better forecast
tornadoes it's also big business right
if we can help inform people and when
they should plant crops inform
investments on how much money should be
spent on heating fuels or something like
that for a winter so there's there's
real economic implications and human
life
State
[Music]